hey vsauce michael here what is the
biggest
number you can think of a google
a google plex a
millimillion olplex well
in reality the biggest number is
40. covering more than 12 000 square
meters of earth
this 40 made out of strategically
planted
trees in russia is larger than the
battalion markers on signal hill
in calgary the six found on the foven
badges in
england even the mile of pie
brady unrolled on numberphile
40 is the biggest number
on earth in terms of surface area but in
terms of amount of things
which is normally what we mean by a
number being big
40 probably isn't the biggest
for example there's 41.
yeah well and then there's 42 and 43
a billion a trillion you know no matter
how big of a number you can think of
you could always go higher so there is
no
biggest last number
except infinity no
infinity is not a number instead it's a
kind of number
you need infinite numbers to talk about
and compare
amounts that are unending but some
unending amounts
some infinities are literally bigger
than others let's visit some of them
and count past them first things first
when a number refers to how many things
there are
it is called a cardinal number for
example
4 bananas 12 flags
20 dots 20 is the
cardinality of this set of dots
now two sets have the same cardinality
when they contain the same number of
things we can demonstrate this equality
by pairing
each member of one set one to one with
each member of the other
same cardinality pretty simple we use
the natural numbers that is 0 1 2 3 4 5
and so on as cardinals whenever we talk
about
how many things there are but how many
natural numbers are there it can't be
some number in the naturals because
there'd always be one plus that number
after it
instead there's a unique name for this
amount
aleph null aleph is the first letter
of the hebrew alphabet and aleph null is
the first
smallest infinity it's how many natural
numbers there are
it's also how many even numbers there
are how many odd numbers there are
it's also how many rational numbers that
is fractions
there are that may sound surprising
since
fractions appear more numerous on the
number line but as cantor showed
there's a way to arrange every single
possible rational
such that the naturals can be put into a
one-to-one correspondence with them
they have the same cardinality
point is aleph null is a big
amount bigger than any finite amount
a google a googleplex a googleplex
factorial to the power of a googleplex
to a googleplex
squared times gram's number
aleph null is bigger
but we can count past it how
well let's use our old friend the
supertask
if we draw a bunch of lines and make
each next line
a fraction of the size and a fraction of
the distance from
each last line well we can fit an
unending number of lines
into a finite space the number of lines
here
is equal to the number of natural
numbers that there are
the two can be matched one to one
there's always a next
natural but there's also always a next
line
both sets have the cardinality out of
null
but what happens when i do this
now how many lines are there aleph null
plus one no unending amounts
aren't like finite amounts there are
still only aleph null lines here because
i can match the naturals one to one just
like before
i just start here and then continue from
the beginning
clearly the amount of lines hasn't
changed
i can even add two more lines three more
four more i always end up with only
aleph null things i can even add another
infinite aleph null of lines
and still not change the quantity every
even number can pair with these and
every odd number
with these there is still a line for
every natural
another cool way to see that these lines
don't add to the total
is to show that you can make this same
sequence without drawing
new lines at all just take every other
line and
move them all together to the end it's
the same thing
but hold on a second this and this
may have the same number of things in
them but clearly there's
something different about them right i
mean if it's not how many things they're
made of
what is it well let's go back to having
just one line
after an aleph null sized collection
what if instead of matching the naturals
one to one we insist on numbering each
line
according to the order it was drawn in
so we have to start here
and number left to right now
what number does this line get in the
realm of the infinite
labeling things in order is
pretty different than counting them you
see this line doesn't contribute to the
total
but in order to label it according to
the order it appeared in
well we need a set of labels of numbers
that extends past the naturals
we need ordinal numbers the first
trans-finite ordinal is omega
the lowercase greek letter omega this
isn't a joke or a trick
it's literally just the next label
you'll need after using up the infinite
collection of every single county number
first
if you got omegath place in a race
that would mean that an infinite number
of people finished the race
and then you did after
omega comes omega plus one which
doesn't really look like a number but it
is just like two or twelve or
eight hundred then comes omega plus two
omega plus three ordinal numbers
label things in order ordinals aren't
about how many things there are
instead they tell us how those things
are arranged
their order type the order type of a set
is just the first ordinal number not
needed to label everything in the set
in order so for finite numbers
cardinality and order type are the same
the order type of all the naturals is
omega
the order type of this sequence is omega
plus one
and now it's omega plus two no matter
how
long an arrangement becomes as long as
it's well ordered
as long as every part of it contains a
beginning element
the whole thing describes a new
ordinal number always
this will be very important later on
it should be noted at this point that if
you are ever playing a game of
who can name the biggest number and you
are considering
saying omega plus one you should be
careful
your opponents might require the number
you name to be a
cardinal that refers to an amount these
numbers
refer to the same amount of stuff just
arranged
differently omega plus one isn't
bigger than omega it just comes
after omega but aleph null
isn't the end why
well because it can be shown that there
are infinities
bigger than aleph null that literally
contain
more things one of the best ways to do
this is with cantor's
diagonal argument in my episode on the
bonnatarsky paradox
i used it to show that the number of
real numbers
is larger than the number of natural
numbers
but for the purposes of this video let's
focus on another thing
bigger than alec nol the power set
of aleph null the power set of a set
is the set of all the different subsets
you can make from
for example from the set of one and two
i can make a set of nothing or
one or two four
one and two the power set of one two
three
is the empty set one and
two and three and one and two
and one and three and two and three and
one two three as you can see
a power set contains many more members
than the original set
two to the power of however many members
the original set had
to be exact so what's the
power set of all the naturals
well let's see imagine a list of every
natural number cool now the subset of
all say
even numbers would look like this yes
no yes no yes no and so on the subset of
all
odd numbers would look like this
here's the subset of just 3 7 and 12.
and how about every number except 5
or no number except five
obviously this list of subsets is going
to be
well infinite but imagine matching them
all
one-to-one with a natural
if even then there's a way to keep
producing
new subsets that are clearly not listed
anywhere here we will know that we've
got a
set with more members than there are
natural numbers
a bigger infinity than aleph null
the way to do this is to start up here
in the first
subset and just do the opposite of what
we see
0 is a member of this one so our
new set will not contain zero next
move diagonally down to one's membership
in the second subset
one is a member of it so it will not be
in our new one
two is not in the third subset so it
will be in
hours and so on
[Music]
as you can see we are describing a
subset that will be
by definition different in at least one
way
from every single other subset on this
aleph null
sized list even if we put this new
subset back in
diagonalization can still be done the
power set
of the naturals will always resist a
one-to-one correspondence
with the naturals it's an infinity
bigger than aleph null repeated
applications of power set
will produce sets that can't be put into
one-to-one correspondence with the last
so it's a great way to quickly produce
bigger and bigger infinities
the point is there are more cardinals
after
aleph null let's try to reach them
now remember that after omega ordinals
split and these numbers are no longer
cardinals
they don't refer to a greater amount
than the last cardinal we reached
but maybe they can take us to one
wait what are we doing
aleph null omega
come on we've been using these numbers
like
there's no problem but if at any point
down here
you can always add one always
can we really talk about it this endless
process as a totality and then follow it
with something
of course we can this is math
not science the things we assume to be
true in math
are called axioms and an axiom we come
up with
isn't more likely to be true if it
better explains or predicts
what we observe instead it's true
because we say it is its consequences
just become what we observe we are not
fitting our theories to some physical
universe
whose behavior and underlying laws would
be the same
whether we were here or not we are
creating
this universe ourselves
if the axioms we declare to be true lead
us to contradictions
or paradoxes we can go back and tweak
them
or just abandon them all together or we
can just refuse to allow ourselves to do
the things that cause the paradoxes
that's it what's fascinating though is
that in making sure the axioms we accept
don't lead to problems we've made math
into something that is as the saying
goes
unreasonably effective in the natural
sciences
so to what extent we're inventing all of
this
or discovering it it's hard to say
all we have to do to get omega
is say let there be omega
and it will be good that's what ernest
zermelo did in 1908 when he included the
axiom of infinity in his list of
axioms for doing stuff in math the axiom
of infinity is simply the declaration
that one infinite set
exists the set of all
natural numbers if you refuse to accept
it
that's fine that makes you a finitist
one who believes only
finite things exist but if you accept it
as most mathematicians do you can go
pretty far past these
and through these eventually we get to
omega plus omega except
we've reached another ceiling going
all the way out to omega plus omega
would be to create another
infinite set and the axiom of infinity
only guarantees that this one exists
are we going to have to add a new axiom
every time we describe aleph null more
numbers no the axiom of replacement can
help us here
this assumption states that if you take
a set like say the set of all natural
numbers
and replace each element with something
else
like say bananas what you're left with
is also a set that sounds simple but
it's incredibly useful
try this take every ordinal up to omega
and then instead of bananas put omega
plus
in front of each now we've reached omega
plus omega
or omega times two using replacement
we can make jumps of any size we want so
long as we only use numbers we've
already
achieved we can replace every ordinal up
to omega
with omega times it to reach omega times
omega
omega squared we're cooking now
the axiom of replacement allows us to
construct
new ordinals without end eventually
we get to omega to the omega to the
omega to the omega to the omega
and we run out of standard mathematical
notation
no problem this is just called epsilon
not
and we continue from here but now
think about all of these ordinals
all the different ways to arrange alec
null things
well these are well ordered so they have
an order type some ordinal that comes
after all of them in this case
that ordinal is called omega 1.
now because by definition omega 1 comes
after
every single order type of aleph null
things
it must describe an arrangement of
literally
more stuff than the last aleph i mean if
it didn't
it would be somewhere in here but it's
not
the cardinal number describing the
amount of things
used to make an arrangement with order
type omega one
is aleph one it's not known where the
power set of the naturals
falls on this line it can't be between
these cardinals
because well there aren't cardinals
between them it could be equal to aleph
one
that belief is called the continuum
hypothesis but it could also be larger
we just don't know the continuum
hypothesis by
the way is probably the greatest
unanswered question in this entire
subject
and today in this video
i will not be solving it but i will be
going higher and higher to bigger
and bigger infinities now using the
replacement axiom we can take any
ordinal we've already reached
like say omega and jump from
aleph to aleph all the way out to al of
omega
or heck why not use a bigger ordinal
like omega squared
to construct alef omega squared alef
omega omega omega omega omega omega
our notation only allows me to add
countably many
omegas here but replacement doesn't care
about whether or not i have a way to
write the numbers it reaches
wherever i land will be a place of even
bigger numbers
allowing me to make even bigger and more
numerous jumps
than before the whole thing is a wildly
accelerating
feedback loop of ambiguity we can keep
going like this
reaching bigger and bigger infinities
from below
replacement and repeated power sets
which may or may not line up with the
aleps
can keep our climb going forever
so clearly there's nothing beyond them
right not so fast that's what we said
about getting past the finite
to omega why not accept as an axiom
that there exists some next number so
big
no amount of replacement or power
setting on anything smaller
could ever get you there such a number
is called
an inaccessible cardinal because you
can't
reach it from below now interestingly
within the numbers we've already reached
a shadow
of such a number can be found aleph null
you can't reach this number from below
either
all numbers less than it are finite
and a finite number of finite numbers
can't be added multiplied exponentiated
replaced with finite jumps a finite
number of times or even
power set a finite number of times to
give you anything
but another finite amount
sure the power set of a millimillion to
a googleplex to a googleplex to a
googleplex
is really big but it's still just finite
not even close to aleph null
the first smallest infinity
for this reason aleph null is often
considered an inaccessible number
some authors don't do this though saying
an inaccessible must also be uncountable
which okay makes sense i mean we've
already accessed
alec null but remember the only way we
could
is by straight up declaring its
existence axiomatically
we will have to do the same for
inaccessible cardinals
it's really hard to get across just how
unfathomable the size of an inaccessible
cardinal is
i'll just leave it at this the
conceptual jump
from nothing to the first infinity
is like the jump from the first infinity
to an inaccessible set theorists have
described numbers
bigger than inaccessibles each one
requiring a new
large cardinal axiom asserting its
existence
expanding the height of our universe of
numbers
will there ever come a point where we
devise an axiom implying the existence
of so many things
that it implies contradictory things
will we someday answer the continuum
hypothesis
maybe not but there are promising
directions
and until then the amazing fact remains
that many of these infinities perhaps
all of them are so big it's
not exactly clear whether they even
truly exist
or could be shown to in the physical
universe
if they do if one day physics finds a
use for them
that's great but if not
that's great too that would mean that we
have
with this brain a tiny thing
a septillion times smaller than the tiny
planet it lives on
discovered something true outside of the
physical realm
something that applies to the real world
but is also strong enough to go
further past what even the universe
itself can contain
or show us or be
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
oh
another interesting fact about
transfinite ordinals
is that arithmetic with them is a little
bit different
normally two plus one is the same as one
plus
two but omega plus one is not the same
as one plus omega one plus omega
is actually just omega think about them
as order types
one thing placed before omega just
uses up all the naturals and leaves us
with order type omega
one thing placed after omega requires
every natural number and then omega
leaving us with omega plus one as the
order type